and with that um I will welcome Pamela
Geller thank you all for coming I want
to thank Alvaro and Tyrone for being
courageous enough to just host a
discussion this is indicative of the low
state of the world where we can have a
conversation
without this kind of vitrio defamation
and
smear freedom of
speech protects all speech not just the
ideas that you like but all ideas
because who decides what's good and
what's forbidden the government the
people in the
street screaming and and heckling uh to
to shut to shut us down why what are you
so afraid of truth is the new hate
speech this Ground Zero Masque deserves
a dialogue whatever happens happens if
they build it they build
it but it is not a religious Liberties
issue it is not a First Amendment issue
there are hundreds of mosques in New
York there are thousands of mosques
across the
country this is a human decency issue
this is a compassion pass an issue of
compassion to build a 15-story mega
mosque in a building that was destroyed
in the attacks on
911 is gross it's deliberately
provocative it's insulting and it's
offensive the Japanese have never asked
to build a Shinto shrine at Pearl Harbor
nor would they why because it's deeply
offensive the the convent outside of
oritz
was uh offensive to many people right or
wrong it offended many people and the
pope withdrew the convent not because he
had to not because there was a law that
said so but because it was the right
thing to
do so we
see constantly even in the daily social
fabric of Our Lives that we need to be
sensitive we we need to respect this
hyper sensitivity in the Muslim world uh
there were some Danish
cartoons that you couldn't run and they
were innocuous you ought to Google it if
you want to see what they were innocuous
tunes that were offensive to Muslims and
no Western media would run them sort of
a self enforced Sharia
yes and embassies burned and people were
slaughtered across the world because of
these 12 innocuous
cartoons the the producers of Comedy
Central put Muhammad in a Huggy Bear
costume and now they're living under
death
threat Comedy Central uh the show was
South Park Comedy Central bleeped out
the word
Muhammad it's
nuts and yet we respect
it we we know that there's this hyper
sensitivity and so we don't run the
cartoons so Molly Norris who was a was a
an unknown cartoonist in Seattle when
she heard that the producers of South
Park were under death threat there was a
fatwa on their head she said well let's
everybody draw Muhammad day that way you
know you can't kill everybody well 48
hours later she withdraws it she
apologizes doesn't matter there's a
fatwa on her head and worse than this
she's had to go into hiding change her
name lost her job lost her home at her
own expense how come the media is not
talking about it she is the media she
represents the
media nobody's mentioning mly noris over
and over again we are schooled in this
hypers sensitivity now the Imam Ru who
many of his audios I've run on my site
he's there in his own
words uh has said some very incendiary
uh uh radical made very uh radical
remarks says that this is a a a Masque
of of healing
now he said it was a mque then he said
it was a press bace a press bace is a
mosque just just for knowing
um a lot of Deceit a lot of deception
and dishonesty and I resent being called
a racist and a bigot because I point out
subversion and
dishonesty so he said he was building it
for healing
Outreach
tolerance but it's had the oppos effect
70% of the American people think it's a
bad idea not for anything we don't like
Muslim nonsense
nonsense there's no better country for
Muslims to live and work and breathe and
Excel than the United States of America
so it's
true and what we do when we give voice
to that to the supremacists because
that's what that is is you make it very
very difficult for the modern
in Islam to speak
up and this is the big mistake I think
of Western media the political Elites
and the
culture because you take someone like RI
kabarry who was a teenage girl that
converted out of
Islam four years ago now her mosque was
spying on her and found out she
converted out of Islam and called the
parents and said you better straighten
her r or else so her father says if you
have this Jesus in your heart I'm going
to kill you she runs away and again here
we see again the the Sharia in America
the girl is pursued across the country
we have runaway girls that are doing
drugs that are selling their bodies that
are prostitutes nobody's looking for
them this little girl straight A student
no drugs no the the whole country is
looking for this girl whose crime was
she converted out of Islam that was a
crime and time and time again we see the
super
supremacists
only their narrative only and this is a
terrible mistake that the West is making
if you look at the ground zero Mass
controversy first of all the media
ignored it as I'm sure you know this is
the first time and I've been doing this
for years that I saw a story become the
number one national news story and
international news story without the
mainstream
media it was unbelievable
people deeply cared about this
issue now this doesn't mean that
nobody's saying that Muslims are bad but
there is an ideology that inspires Jihad
there have been 20,000 Islamic attacks
since
911 all with the Imp matter of a Muslim
cleric what is being done to
expunge these texts that Inspire Jihad
nothing not only is nothing being done
but the supremacists are dictating what
we can and cannot
say they these the these kids shouldn't
have had a hard time bringing this
conversation I will debate anybody on
the merits on the merits on the
concretes not on the assumptions this is
what they do they defame they smear I am
a human rights activist activist I work
against honor killings I work against
clitorectomies I work against the
subjugation of women those are people
too
[Applause]
they have rights they have rights and
this is what's being this is what's what
what what's being Miss missing from the
dialogue this
country this unique and magnificent
experiment in human history the first
moral government in human
history was was founded on the principle
of individual
rights that's the founding principle
everybody's rights not just those or no
special rights for special classes
equal rights for everybody now as I said
he's going to he wants to build this
Masque that is tearing this country
apart the divisiveness the Discord the
dialogue the name
calling that's what he sought to
achieve and look it is an Islamic
pattern to build triumphal mosques on
the cherish
sites of conquered lands now you could
say well well that's not what's in his
mind it's a
pattern thousands and thousands of
mosques have been built on top of or in
lie of or taking over St Sophia D with
The Rock was the most the holiest site
in Jewish history do the first temple
they built it right on top thousands and
thousands so you can't say it's not
going to be perceived that way you can't
say that that's exactly how it's going
to be perceived people have a right to
be upset about this people have a right
to appeal to the Imam and say move it or
don't put the mask there do something
else have a center dedicated to
expunging the Quran of its violent texts
or how about well right wouldn't that be
healing why not a memorial to the 270
million victims over a millennium of
Jihadi Wars land Appropriations cultural
annihilations and ins Slavs when are we
being able to talk about this subject in
an honest fashion BAS on concretes not
whitewashing not historical inaccuracy
when did concretes become
irrelevant facts are your
friends you can have your own opinion
you cannot have your own
facts and so we ask and this is all
we've been doing with the rallies in a
peaceful manner we're asking the Imam to
to to to move the mask yes that's what
we're
doing and I'll tell you something that I
find his callous dismissiveness of the
grief and the pain that he's caused to
be radically
intolerant I find his dishonesty to be
deeply troubling I find his remarks that
you know the US has more Muslim blood on
its hands than than alqaeda has the
blood of of no Al yeah the US has more
Muslim blood on his hands and Al Qaeda
has the blood of non-muslims innocent
non-muslims is a key word there because
in devout Islam there are no innocent
non-muslims you would be a Muslim if you
were an innocent
non-muslim I mean time and again the US
was an accessory to 911 and he says this
right after 911 think about that I mean
everybody was still in
blowback he's a leading member of the
Pano organization in Malaysia the
largest funer of the ter Turkish
terrorist group P um IAH that funded the
Jihad warship
flotillas uh I got to tell you something
I know he talks the talk I know he
speaks to the English press and says he
believes in Interfaith dialogue but he
says to the Arabic press there's no such
thing as Interfaith
dialogue there is a a a a level of
deception even the name Cordoba or Corda
whatever invokes and is Iconic in the
Muslim world of Islamic conquest over
the West in 7-Eleven Muslim armies March
into Spain which was a collection of
Christian kingdoms and conquered Spain
and they say well it was a golden age it
was wonderful we all living together in
peace and Harmony well not according to
the Christians and Jews who had to live
under dimude and were denied basic human
rights was the sight of not one but two
two programs against the Jews thousand
Slaughters mamones had to
flee again this whitewashing of history
now don't you think that the American
people deserve to have this conversation
whichever way it goes do you think that
people should should be shut up and
defamed and smeared and and liel for
saying hey I'm
offended we live in a puristic and
Multicultural Society because we respect
our neighbors because we are kind to our
neighbors because if all of us did
whatever we wanted to do that was legal
under the law it would be pure chaos
that's not who we are it's not what we
do and I can assure you that that
Cordova mosque will be the rallying
cry the icon on their jackets of the
global Jihad there's there's no question
about it Mecca on the Hudson I think
it's a very bad idea so we ask him
that's all we're asking the Imam to
reconsider what he's been doing and I
don't know if you saw the design of the
mosque with the with the the what did
what do they call it in the guardian oh
an homage to all religions there were
crashing Jewish stars there were
pentagons on there I mean oh my God it's
like The Emperor's New Clothes but
where's the little boy we need the
little
boy I'm going to turn the mic over to
Robert and then I'll be happy to answer
any questions about my imaginary racist
islamophobic anti-muslim bigotry
[Applause]